it was a speech delivered from a bunker
in kiev but with this audience in his
sights
u.s lawmakers are captivated by this man
the president of ukraine vladimir
zelinsky
flava ukrana with people watching in
homes across america he invoked the
country's greatest tragedies
remember september the 11th
a terrible day in 20 2001 when he will
try to turn your cities our
country
experience the same every day right now
without warning mr zielenski played this
video showing how his country is being
terrorized in a packed auditorium some
members wiped away tears it ended with
this message one he knows has little
chance of being approved then pointedly
a pivot to english and a direct plea to
president biden
i wish you
to be the leader of the world
being the leader of the world means
to be the leader
of peace
thank you
filing out lawmakers on both sides of
the political aisle were moved
well it was
incredibly effective and
i think the message to president biden
is he needs to step up his game the way
the people of ukraine behave every day
is having a profound effect on our
country and all around the world do you
think president biden is scared of
antagonizing president putin
i think we should be more
focused on keeping putin worried about
what we might do rather than spending
our time worried about what he might do
he after all has invaded a sovereign
free nation
with pressure on him ratcheting up
president biden made this declaration
about vladimir putin for the first time
oh i i think he is a worker
he also pledged 800 million dollars in
military aid for ukraine including
drones and anti-aircraft missiles these
are direct transfers of equipment from
our department of defense to the
ukrainian military to help them as they
fight against this invasion
on president zielenski's request for a
no-fly zone the white house remain
unmoved they're treading a fine line
they say between helping ukraine's
defense and not sparking a broader
conflict in washington it's the key
political balancing act of this war
martha kellner sky news washington